okay so we have a first question from
Larissa Larissa hi ed hi the extent of
children's exposure to over sexualized
content in the media is unacceptable
what will you do in the coming electoral
term to change that I think it's a
really important problem Larissa and
it's something we do have to look at I
think there's a responsibility on
advertisers on television programs I
think that's where it starts I think we
have to look at issues of default
settings and on the internet in relation
to children and young people but I think
that most of all there's also a role for
parents and there's a role for parents
to make sure that they protect their
children from content they shouldn't be
seeing so how do you intend to instill
the knowledge in Paris of how to do
these things and how to make the
differences that will stop the children
being exposed it's partly about being
able to keep a watch on what your kids
are up to the parents really hard I mean
my kids are four and five so not yet
kind of looking at hopefully the things
they shouldn't be looking at but they
are even at that age you know using the
iPad having a look at things that's why
I think look at these issues of default
settings parental control and giving
parents you know warning parents and
giving parents proper information about
how to avoid their kids being exposed to
the wrong things is the way forward but
I'd say this also the Internet is a
great thing and the freedom of the
Internet is a great thing and we've
always got to be sure to protect that
let's bring in someone else on this
issue anyone from this side on that
issue on the freedom of the Internet
okay just well you're gonna have a
question later let's let's pass it back
here it comes the front
hi name's Luke Luke as you were saying
there you want to protect the sanctity
of the Internet keeping it a free space
for people yeah but it's very clear that
it can become it can go the other way
and become a nanny state what are you
gonna try and do to avoid that I think
it's about that balance and I think it's
about information for parents most of
all and it's about issues like the
default setting so there's parental
control so you got to choose to lift
those parental
or controls but so that's the way
forward I think so you don't want it to
be a situation where the government
enforce a system to prevent internet
access but more of an educating the
parents and the people I think the most
is education and empowerment of parents
that that's the key for me so I'm off to
uni in September and I know that a lot
of young people like me would say that
graduate unemployment is something that
it's quite scary after we finish uni so
just wants to know like she gets power
what you'd be doing at law with
international relations great subject
yeah well there's a couple of things I'd
say to you the first is I think too many
of the jobs in our economy and I think
this does go to the big choice at this
election our zero-hours contracts jobs
insecure jobs I think we like a race to
the bottom so lower skill lower wage
jobs I think we've got we've got a drive
drive that out you know in the sense
that we've got to say well look if
you're working regular hours you should
get a regular contract not a zero hours
contract and then you've got to create
the good jobs of the future let me give
you one example tangible example of
where I think the good jobs can come
from take these for climate change which
I care about a lot you might think
that's an environmental issue it's not
just an environmental issue it's also a
jobs issue by leading in renewable
technology by doing the right things
giving companies incentives to invest
that creates great jobs for our young
people so let's make sure we have a race
to the top in high skill high wage jobs
not a race to the bottom in low-skill
low-wage jobs let me take this mic and
give it to you Brendan
how would you encourage graduate jobs
outside of London and South East on
those days because even though London is
a great place to come and work it would
be nice if there were more opportunities
outside London as well yeah it's a it's
a big issue isn't it
you know I'm an MP and Doncaster and I
and I see this myself I think we kind of
know what makes for successful towns and
cities which is actually having higher
educational college educated people
that's part of the answer giving proper
transport links that's part the answer
and there's really one other thing which
is really important with far too
centralized
in the way where power is so when it
comes to decisions about what matters to
local people so much of it takes place
in Westminster and in Whitehall now
we've heard a lot about devolution to
Scotland and Wales I think it's time we
have some devolution in England as well
so you know when I think about my
council and the area that I'm in I want
more powers of our economic development
transport skills the things that will
actually create the good jobs at decent
wages that our economy needs last
question on this topic just over there
there's a microphone coming your way
thank you hi my name is Percy
hi I'm a reporter on a program called
London 360 which is run bundle 360 which
is run by media trusts and it's a great
scheme that teaches diverse people like
myself all the skills needed to become a
multi-platform journalist now I chose
the scheme because I've seen that form
of reporters have gone on to get secure
permanent roles in the industry but one
of the things I see if a lot of schemes
up for diverse young people is that they
give a foot in the door but they don't
give enabled as people to secure
permanent roles so I want to know how
you think companies can get a balance
between ticking boxes and having
diversity and getting diverse companies
but also providing those permanent
secure votes of people is that a foot in
the door I was watching earlier on when
you're talking to Natalie Bennett is
this foot in the door like unpaid
internships or do you mean a more of a
foot in the door than that but not a
proper foot in the door if you like they
may be unpaid they may be paid they may
be six weeks and maybe two weeks it's
not permanent job roles lots of people
will jump from scheme to scheme without
so I just wanted to know how you thought
companies can sort of change that
culture I think there's a there's a
couple of things about this you know I
think that good work experience and I'm
sure there's people here who's had good
experience in terms of work experience
it's really important but I think that
there's a kind of place where work
experience ends and you know unpaid
internships are just exploiting people
begin and I think that we've got to look
at having some limits on these unpaid
internships because I think I think we
cut for me the injustice is you can only
do it if you can afford it and therefore
you're giving a foot on the ladder to
one group of people but not like another
group of people so I think we've got a
look at whether we can play some limits
on these unpaid internships and I also
think it goes to your point about
temporary and permanent employment we
got to do more to encourage companies
not to opt for the insecure work that's
why I say what I said that zero hours
contract and you know that is just a
massive dozen massive grosses by the way
zero hours contracts midlow hours
contracts it could be two hours or four
hours contracts so I think part of it is
about setting the right regulations to
kind of if you like incentivize
companies not to go down that road and
looking at that crucial issue of in
unpaid internships
let's move on to the next issue we've
got a push for time Adam hi yeah I was
wondering recently there's been a lot of
media coverage on right-wing parties and
their popularity
are you worried by this tool in talking
about things like you keep and people
like that you know I'm incredibly proud
of the fact that we're an open tolerant
country I'm the son of immigrants my
parents came here as refugees from the
Nazis and I think that is one of the
great things about Britain that we are
open and tolerant that the view I take
about this is we've got a kind of
champion openness and our diversity but
we've got to make it work let me give
you one specific example where I think
it doesn't work at the moment you get a
situation where people are being brought
here pay less than the minimum wage or
15 people being put in a house now that
exploits migrant workers but it also
undercuts wages so you see I think most
of the time people's of concerns aren't
based on prejudice they're based on
reality when people see that happening
they said well MIT that's not fair we've
got to do something about it so let's
have the openness and tolerance that is
brilliant for for Britain you know it
was the heart of the London Olympics but
let's also make sure we make that vision
of the tolerant diverse society work for
everybody and not just for for some
people because if you have a society
where there's wages are being driven
down people say well hang on a minute
that doesn't seem like that vision is
working for me is there anyone from
those parties here he wants to follow up
they won't form oh they're they're being
shy okay are you happy with that answer
oh yeah thank you okay well let's move
on to a question from social media from
Facebook from Kevin - how will you
ensure tax incurred in the UK gets paid
in the UK and goes to those who need it
most
well this is a really important question
that Kevin asks
and there's nothing I think that annoys
people more than tax avoidance by big
companies now I think a couple of things
first of all we've got to act
internationally because that's the best
way of clamping down on this but also
we've got to be willing to act on our
own there are other countries like
Denmark and others who do a much better
job of actually clamping down on tax
avoidance by big firms now this is in
the news at the moment because yesterday
the chairman of Bhoots started telling
people how to vote in the UK general
election well it turns out that the
chairman of beats lives in Monaco and is
actually avoiding his taxes now you know
I've just got to say to you I don't
think people in Britain are gonna take
kindly to being lectured by somebody
who's avoiding his taxes on how they
should be voting at the UK general
election and you've now got this unholy
alliance between the Conservative Party
and people like him who are actually
saying that the country can't change I
think we can change the country and I
think part of my job is to say we're
gonna stand up to these powerful forces
who aren't paying their taxes or
avoiding their taxes because frankly
they have a responsibility you know we
talk a lot about responsibility in our
society
I think responsibility goes from top to
bottom in our country now how can we say
to people on benefits and others you
should be responsible what some of the
top people some of the most powerful
people in our country are avoiding their
taxes are not doing the right thing so
mr. piscina who's been trying to lecture
us about what we should be doing in this
country frankly I think you should be
paying his taxes I don't want to come
back on that quite a statement are you
stating categorically that corporations
economic elites will be paying tax in
the UK like Amazon and Google absolutely
we've got to deal with this you know
we've got to deal with this it's what
they call this profit shifting so they
shift profits and I mean you all heard
of it by now where they shift profits
around the world to avoid paying them in
this country and to sort of if you like
put them in countries where there are
much lower tax rates this is something
the world has got to get to grips with
and by the way there's a really
important point in this James which is
this is about businesses this is about
decent businesses in this country small
businesses large businesses who are
doing the right thing the vast majority
are doing the right thing and frankly
there is knocked as we are about the
fact that you know there are some people
and some businesses who are not doing
there
thing and we got to clamp down on it
Molly you've got a book you just come to
the front for us please thank you do we
not already have systems in place to
make sure that they do pay their taxes
in their own way it's not happening
Molly you know the actual tax gap
between actually what the companies
should be paying or what is being paid
is just going up and up and up under
this government and we've got to clamp
down why do you think it's not being
done properly well if I think because
there's been a view and this goes to the
heart of this election there's been a
view that went powerful people or
powerful companies say this is the way
it should be that's the way what we
should accept and I just don't agree
with that you know as leader of the
Labor Party
I took on Rupert Murdoch of a phone
hacking I took on the energy companies
over their prices because I actually
think you need a prime minister who will
actually stand up and be counted
on behalf of ordinary people in this
country and to use the line no pun
intended you know so I think that is a
big change and that is a big issue at
stake in this election don't you think
that deter large international companies
coming to the UK and recruiting and
setting up businesses in the UK well
that's what they say and that's what the
banks used to say you think about the
financial crash and you know I've taken
our responsibility because we didn't
regulate the banks enough in government
you know the bank said don't regulate us
because if you regulate us we'll leave
the country and we won't be here well
actually turned out a bit more
regulation would have been quite a good
thing and it would have prevented what
we're seeing now in our country I don't
buy it frankly I think there are lots
and lots of reasons for people to invest
in Britain and be in Britain and there
are lots as I say of really decent
businesses in our country big big names
who also say to me hang on a minute you
know we pay our taxes you know we're on
the high street we're doing the right
thing you know why are these other
people not doing the right thing as well
I think it's a pro-business argument and
frankly you eight people in my
constituency are paying the price of the
financial crisis I don't want to see a
society where those at the top are just
getting away with it I don't think we
can allow it any more convinced by okay
next question again from Facebook how do
you I'm gonna read it from here how do
you seriously expect Scotland the
spiritual home and heart
of your party to remain behind you after
standing shoulder-to-shoulder with the
Tories how can we trust labor to do
rights by Scotland that's from Sean
James Cosmo what shawne's asking an
important question
everybody will know that last year we
had the independence debate in Scotland
by 55 to 45 Scotland decided to stay in
the United Kingdom I'm very pleased that
it did now there are a number of parties
who wanted Scotland to stay in the
United Kingdom including the
Conservatives labour the Liberal
Democrats but this year there's a
different choice and what I'd say to
Sean and anybody watching this in
Scotland and voting in Scotland is
there's a choice at this election
between a Labour government a
Conservative government well either be
me as Prime Minister or or David Cameron
that that's what people are saying
including people in in Scotland Nicola
Sturgeon the leader of the SNP I think
people in Scotland want change they want
a different way forward for the country
and I think what we're offering Scotland
is actually some things that will make a
real difference like a bank bonus tax
for our young people back to work like a
mansion tax on the most expensive homes
which will help fund the NHS including
in in Scotland like greater fairness in
our society so I understand why Sean I
don't know whether he was a yes voter in
that referendum campaign I know that he
you know how why he feels what he does
and why he says what he says what I'd
say to Sean is there's a big choice at
this election between a Labour
government a Tory government I have a
huge set of differences with David
Cameron about the way the country should
be run it's got the next question
actually we're just gonna push on with
James's question actually just to move
on to a question about yourself yeah and
outside of politics what experience do
you have what life experience do you
have to associate and indicate that you
should be the one to represent the
people of Britain well I've done a
number of things which I think I hope
are relevant to this so I was obviously
an economic adviser in the Treasury and
I think that's important I think that's
important because you know the economy
and how we change our economy is at the
heart of the country
I've taught I taught at Harvard
University I actually taught around
government and economics and I think
that actually one of the things that
that did for me being able to teach was
actually the the ability to be able I
hope to listen and engage with people
about what what their issues are what
their interests
I also go back to this which is about
what politics is about but I think this
is the big you know this is a really
important issue why am I in politics you
might you might wonder ah because I
think it makes a difference to our
country and I mentioned earlier my
parents the the background and the
history they had which was you know
fleeing persecution and now this is why
I stand up and be counted it's so
important by the way if you said to my
mom who's 18 now if you said to her
politics doesn't matter she said don't
be ridiculous you know her dad was
killed by the Nazis she had to flee to
Britain now fortunately we're not
dealing with those issues but the reason
I say that to James is that I was
brought up by my parents to think you've
got a duty to leave the world a better
place than you found it with the
experience they had they said to me look
you can't just ignore the world you
can't just ignore injustice in the world
you've actually got to deal with it so
that explains some of why I'm in
politics and some of the experience I've
had I mean I personally think that
there's this dejection in politics
because of the political paradigm not
just with politics because all speaking
about politics ourself in our social
groups and I think one of the issues is
that me myself I feel like I have more
in common with perhaps people who
represent my views but not in politics
for example I've only just met the
people around me today and I feel like
I've got more in common with them and
then perhaps I deal with David Cameron I
think that is the issue I think I've got
more in common with you than David
Cameron as well but but but I think
you'll make an important point about
this I sometimes say politics is too
important to be left to politicians and
in a way there's a slightly odd thing
for a politician to say but the reason I
say that is because it's people that
change things but you want very brief
example if I can take lesbian and gay
rights the biggest change I've seen
since I was growing up since I was your
age is the change in the rights for
lesbian gay people it didn't happen
because nice politicians said we want it
to happen sure Tony Blair was important
and his government was important but
it's because people said we've got to
have change take this talking about tax
avoidance let's be honest about it it's
been led by people not by government and
so what
I think your point in a way is right I
think I think that the world we live in
people are less interested in one size
fits all philosophies you know what I
mean so you'll have different views on
different issues you've got to make a
judgement though about who's gonna best
represent what you want to see as the
government but I think being engaged in
politics and demanding change is
absolutely crucial and it's not just me
that needs to do that just on this sort
of personal credentials that Mr Miliband
what you were saying about young people
being able to engage and it follows on
from that question nicely and parties
present their manifestos and I don't
think at any point that they do it in a
way that's suitable for young people
about creating youth friendly manifesto
so we can actually start to understand
what's going some really important
question we've got we're gonna have a
young people's manifesto now I launched
that process a couple of weeks ago you
should go to the labor website to look
at how you can get engaged with that I
think it's incredibly important that we
have a young manifesto that does reflect
the wishes of young people let me add
one other point to Elizabeth and then
come back we're going to give the vote
to 16 and 17 year olds now one of some
people might being favorite that some
people might be against it why do I
think it's important there are one and a
half million 16 and 17 year-olds take
the EMA for example it was abolished in
one sentence of a budget speech without
and I think in George Osborne wouldn't
have done that if actually he thought 16
and 17 year olds can vote but it's also
about trust in young people I think we
want to hear the voices of young people
more in our politics but you come back
and say to me what you think we should
be doing that we're not I just think
that what you stand for as a party and
it goes for all the parties that should
be broadcast in simple points we should
know exactly what you sample and that
should be done by social media online
and agreed great so I'm gonna move on to
maybe as Prime Minister how would you
engage with the vast majority of
peaceful patriotic British Muslims to
tackle the extremist ideology of Isis
and will you start to heed the advice of
British Muslims that our foreign policy
is a factor in the radicalization of
young people and will you reconsider
Britain's international State Britain's
international stage with the Muslim
world
Mabini cesare really
it's a really important question let me
say a couple of things first of all
about what we should be doing here at
home and secondly what we should be
doing internationally
what we should be doing here at home I
think what's what we know about
radicalization of young people is the
best thing we can do is prevent it
happening not deal with it after it
happens and what I want to see a lot
more of is engaging with young Muslims
community groups and others there's a
program called prevent now that's the
moment led by the police I think it
should be actually much more about
community groups and saying how do we
prevent radicalization which we all
share but the second thing I'd say to
you is this look on foreign policy I
have changed our position but I think
the war in Iraq was a mistake and I've
said that right so would you would you
agree that foreign policy is a factor in
the radicalization yes or no I think it
is being used I think it is being used
to say to people that somehow they
should kind of take a different view and
take an extremist view but I've got to
say to you think about ISIL right ISIL
is killing Muslims all over the world
they are not indiscriminate about who
they kill they kill Muslims they kill
Christians they kill your cities they
kill people you know people without any
religion so so I think I can see how
it's exploited and the last thing I'd
say to you is this you said in your
question the vast majority of Muslims
are poured leave the ideology I think
that is absolutely right and I think one
of the things I've got to do as a
politician and all politicians should be
doing is emphasizing that point not
saying this is a problem for the Muslim
community of course the Muslim community
has a responsibility but actually what
he's seen in the in relation to the
events in Paris for example the terrible
terror set is the Muslim community in
Britain speaking out about this issue
there was another person was it behind
me he wanted to come in on this sorry I
just wanted to kind of build on the on
the point you said that radicalization
has been built upon things that are
being said about these things that are
being said are being said by the
newspapers and the news organizations
that you are in charge with that you are
in charge of not necessarily regulating
we're making sure that they're getting
the right messages across I think if I
was in charge of the newspaper but only
they'd be quite writing what they are
about me
there's there's a degree of
responsibility about around what exactly
is it you're in charge of and in in that
sense what would you what would you do
will say to kind of help bring around
the change you wanted to bring in terms
of making sure that people are seen in a
more positive light can I just clarify
you're saying that the media is
responsible for this noticing it was
possible in their own but they
definitely they definitely play a big
part if you've got a newspaper desk I
like you know the first say for example
his son and immediately on the front
page is plotted in Islamophobic comments
or headlines and that's the first minute
you see it can become a very very big
issue for a huge chunk of society well
I'd say a couple of things first of all
I made a joke about the newspapers they
sometimes give me a hard time will often
give me a hard time that's actually part
of a free society it is not for me to
say this is what the son would write or
this is what somebody else should should
write I'd say this you know look all of
us as politicians journalists others and
I think and lots of them recognizes have
a responsibility to talk about these
issues in the right way
and by the way there's one other thing
I'd say let's speak out against
prejudice against Islamophobia against
anti-semitism which I know was asked
about earlier on wherever we find it I
think that is the most important
principle but because but because if we
speak out about these things and if we
say this is wrong and we're not gonna
live as a society that is how best in
short you know goes back to the question
I said answer I gave earlier it is about
politicians but it's about all of us as
a community speaking out against these
things I think I'm gonna push on to
Barbara for the next question I just
quickly wanted to say I probably
wouldn't have gone to university without
EMA so I think the if you probably can
reaffirm bringing EMA back that would
just basically be great yeah I mean I
know that the Labor Party made an
announcement last year about bring it
back here may feel Ector so I was just
saying that you know we need to look at
all of these things Barbara I will say
one thing to you though I can't at the
moment promise to bring it back and I'll
tell you why because we've got to make
the sums an up and we've got to get the
deficit down and you know there is one
issue here which I do want to go to
about politics and why people are so
cynical about politics lots of
politicians come along in opposition and
basically say I'm going to make a
promise to you on a program
this and then I'll really hope you don't
catch up with me in government and if I
do if you do I'll kind of run around the
corner and hope I can avoid you I don't
think we can do that so look we're gonna
look at all of these issues but we'll
make promises we know we can keep on all
of these things just go to you yeah yeah
I mean I just think that if you vest in
young people they're gonna you know move
on like like I have to university get a
degree and contribute to the economy so
I think stop I think we should stop
focusing on deficit like everybody has
debt that's how the cup to this economy
worse I think we should talk more about
investing in people I think look we're I
think Barbara you're totally right about
this is that this government has loaded
lots of its plans on Deficit Russian on
young people the trebling of the tuition
fee what's happening to apprenticeships
a whole range of other things I think
it's really important and you need lots
of young people are saying I'm worried
I'm gonna have a more difficult life
than my parents so that's why we're so
committed for example on a jobs
guarantee for young people why we want a
real revolution in vocational education
for young people apprenticeships for
young people so we say young people who
go to university and those who don't get
you to go to university and have proper
opportunity and there's something else
which i think is really important may
come up which is what's happening in the
private rented sector for young people
housing for young people I think so many
young people are being really ripped off
and we've got to have a better deal for
them we're gonna move on you were going
to ask about that but you've got a
couple of questions already let's go to
a question from Facebook from Blair
Pettigrew do labor agree with the
pensions cuts imposed on the public
service most officers working more
paying more getting back less so I think
that's pretty about police officer it is
about police officers yes you know this
is the hardest you this pensions issue
so the first thing I'd say is I think we
are all gonna have to work longer as a
society now this may be kind of bad news
in a way but the reality is that we we
live with an aging population I think
that's a great thing but if you think
shears have well how are we going to
support that aging population we are
gonna have to work longer now the thing
I don't like about some of the things
the government did on this pensions
issue was that they didn't do it with
proper dialogue and negotiation and they
did it with very short notice for people
so people will be saying well I'm about
to retire or I'm five years from
retirement and suddenly they're moving
the goalposts
I can't make I'm not gonna make false
promises on this but I think the
approach has got to be a principle that
says look we are gonna have to work
longer than a society but we've got to
do this in the right way and in a way
that's fair
Sam Townsend quick question actually you
know it's the Greek people decide who
they elect obviously for the British
people decide who they elect I think we
do have an alternative and and here's
the alternative that the government says
that we're less than halfway through the
cuts they're gonna make so they want to
take public spending back to the levels
of the 1930s as a share of our national
income that's before there was a
National Health Service now I think that
will do terrible damage to the country
we've got a better plan
which is to say let's have those with
the borders shoulders bearing the
greatest burden so we're going to
reverse a millionaire's tax cut that
David Cameron gave to the richest in our
society we will make common-sense
reductions in spending because I don't
think we can say well the deficit you
know the deficit isn't an issue isn't
it's you've got to balance the books but
here's the most important thing you
might be thinking the cost-of-living
crisis that so many people are facing
well that's a really big issue for many
people and it is for working people
having less pounds in your pockets in
your wages for the reason the government
hasn't met its deficit plan is because I
haven't had that boost in wages that we
need so part of our plan say let's run
the economy in a different way let's
have higher wages higher skills that
will actually help pay down the deficit
so I think as is a much more balanced
sensible plan okay right
well we'll I'm sorry we've run out of
time but you'll get the first girl on
the facebook Q&A that's coming up I'm
sorry about that there's only half an
hour we've got that's it for this
session ed miliband thank you very much
later we'll be joined by the
those will beat all other political
leaders at the Lib Dems and the
Conservatives if you still have
questions for Mr Miliband he will be
answering those in the live Facebook Q&A
as soon as he comes off set and we'll
have a full analysis coming up you can
join in the debate on social media just
use the hashtag ask the leaders